welcome to Co play black against
Westphalia
another German opponent may be right
from my area of Germany there's
something in that I don't think so
nope I just accidentally pressed vas
that's this function it tells me that
this guy is playing on check is playing
on an iPad okay yeah maybe the sir is
not really helping him in terms of speed
okay we have the nimzo-indian Huebner
variation what normally castles see I
can also go a form but it seems that
he's not very familiar with things again
efore here is the traditional move 92 as
another option
now e5d 597 is my father
the main continuation and here white has
a somewhat wide choice the move Knight H
force traditionally the main line
intended to play F form a form while
this is also possible in fact it was
played against me against Grandmaster
noises of æneas from from Lithuania back
in this open tournament that played on
my account
early early May and we had this this is
this structure okay we get some traits
in which I don't mind black is some
normally were coming some traits here
his let's say dream scenario as an
endgame with the single night against
this specific Bishop only three so
Knight f5 Queen f5 and a queen trade
this is very close to being
positionally bankrupt form for white so
it probably won't happen at least the
Queen's you should keep on the bone okay
I can take now play Queen f5 which I
probably will do keep it keep it simple
and try to exchange this the Queen tray
now is some a very serious I have a very
serious strategic mistake now black is
substantially better the only thing that
I need to do now is straight trade rooks
not that is so easy to do but this is
the general plan that I'd like to pursue
okay I can try to double against the
pawn but I can set up this 7th ranked
defense I guess I guess I can and should
you know that the problem might be that
while this is of course quite nice for
black the problem might be that it is
not so easy to convert how to get the
rooks off I probably should aim for a
regrouping
this is preventing of any Bishop g5 ok
threatening 94 but it won't happen ok um
I want to actually this was my idea get
the King over King over to c8 to protect
the b7 pawn so that at least one of my
looks get mobile again
it would also be very nice if I can
manage to yeah maybe I can manage
somehow to move the b-pawn like exchange
it for the apron and then maybe open up
the position somehow not quite sure yet
how to possibly do that but at least now
the king is Sam is a good supporting
piece yeah maybe
oh he's opening up the position that's
interesting mmm efore is good 97 I might
might have f5 after that if I go Knight
h5 by the way what is his move then
threatening to take on f4 and I'm
threatening Nigeria yeah seems to be a
good move just tactically motivated
hmm yeah I can take I can play 93 m or e
for 93 it's also quite attractive if I
go 93 might just take if fire
so maybe if or check first check okay
takes 93 wins the exchange and key III I
just also go to g3 okay he's giving up
the exchange so check it's um it's
probably not such a bad idea to do that
how to play this now should i I probably
should play h5 to make it more difficult
yeah no no I have the age phone so I can
enter here maybe Russia to to to attack
oh I completely forgot that you can
advance it
hmm well that's not good nothing
terrible but haven't for some reason I
have big not the idea that he can
advance it's not so easy for him to play
them something like f6 I'll just take g6
our take f3 hangs it's not the easy
route king c2 runs into and self-pity I
can just take this I hope right it
probably was bad anyway really like
reason I have a head simply overlooked
g5 but it wasn't really mentoring much
the problem is that this structure the
whole structures was very it's very
prospectus for white you're always
facing a bad minor piece and game and if
rooks are traded it's really a very
one-sided affair I really think that
around here yeah and it's very difficult
for white to devise any active plan he
played this f4 which after Knight h5 I
think just runs into problems computer
gives a better defense though what to
sit computer this is not good according
to the machine that wants to play rook
f3 okay
okay I see based on the fact that check
oli have a take here he has this this
kind of counter plymouth we okay this is
always the e6 square being weak and yeah
this is a very serious count to play
against the pawns so I cannot really I
can also hear this is even G for coming
interesting and then need to return the
pawn
okay this is then still okay okay if he
can't play F for under the right
circumstances then maybe the whole thing
is is good or I must play actually
something like this to to prevent f4 for
the time being I didn't think I needed
to prevent it but maybe I can insured
this is not a terrible position but this
is for wide I mean but it's always very
tricky to play as you run the risk to go
into a very bad minor and game situation
with the knight being much better
generally after before I'm just winning
material we can of course try to not
take it can play something like that now
I'm coming with this year maybe also the
H pawn I just have this dangerous pawn
of the II found and White's pieces are
not coordinated wrong it does not look
good so she decided to give up the
exchange and here it's strictly after
age five he cannot really get anything
going without the Jeep on moving at some
stage and he did it right away after
which I'm invading and I don't think
this can be any good with both my rooks
playing a useful role f5 no this one was
played uh-huh maybe g6 is stronger here
yeah
g6 is even stronger
okay this wasn't wasn't bad for some
reason I didn't cg5 don't ask me it
doesn't make any sense I know King g7
and TR he blundered upon but it's
difficult to keep this position together
always have some way to increase some
activity of my pieces something like
this could be an idea I must be very
cautious though they have poorness is
dangerous and advanced quickly this
isn't totally easy I mean black is
substantially better but how to win is
it's maybe I'm still an open question
not so sure how I how to bring this
action when it is reasonably well
coordinated if we just sing say this
hymn and how do I increase some Mike
pivot team this kind of stuff is
possible and let's say why does just
waiting what am I doing here I mean
something like this he just gets this to
this pong going it's not totally easy I
mean I will try and maybe succeed at the
end but it's not an easy win
ok thanks for watching